burn all your hopes and dreams of a good
season into Dragon Fire and kill off
your characters you love in falling
debris because we have the writing
equivalent of the Hindenburg hey guys
I'm not really sure how to begin this
episode I've been a die-hard Game of
Thrones fan since day one and even after
the last few weeks of other YouTube
commentary channels [ __ ] on the
series saying it's dead I didn't want to
believe it did I think the writing was
getting worse yes but enough for me to
stop enjoying it
no but tonight's episode changed all of
that I can no longer sit idly by as the
writers of the show completely destroy
eight seasons of character and plot with
decisions that are so out of the realm
of possibility that it makes me question
what they were thinking so before you go
ahead and dislike this video I want you
to hear my side and join me as we break
down this episode and point out some of
the flaws that I think hindered this
from being one of the greatest series of
all time and please leave your comments
below I'll be reading them tell me how
wrong I am but know that my complaints
are coming from a place of absolute love
for this show love and anger the episode
begins with Varys writing a treasonous
note revealing that Jon Snow is the true
heir to the Iron Throne we already know
Varys is always playing the game of
Thrones and when Jon lands in
Dragonstone he makes his intentions
clear he wants the right ruler on the
throne aka John but John is still loyal
to Danny Danny is moping because she
knows Jon has betrayed her
she made Jon swear that he hold the
secret about his true lineage but he
told Sansa who in turn told Tyrion now
the secret is out of the bag and she
isn't dealing too well with it this is
the end of Dany the woman we've seen
struggle so long Four Seasons to get to
the Iron Throne is turning mad just like
her father before her I'm willing to
forgive this but it seems achingly
unsatisfactory that we've been with her
for so long just to have her submit to
this same fate of her father even season
after season she's told us she's not
like her father and that we shouldn't be
held accountable for the sins of our
father varus is killed as a traitor
stating that he hopes in the end he's
wrong but with the way Danny acts this
episode it looks like varus's death is a
tragic loss especially for someone who
has claimed he's always supported the
best interest of their realm and perhaps
he was right
Danny confronts John claiming that Sansa
is just as much at fault for varus's
death than she is
she even threatens him stating that now
Sansa will know what happens when people
know the truth and this is somehow
supposed to make things romantic john
has literally been by your side every
step of the way and you can't sit down
as civil human beings and work this out
he doesn't even want the throne he loves
you and yet she's still on the defensive
Tyrion makes a plea to Daenerys that she
doesn't use her dragon to burn the
civilians within King's Landing but Dany
has gone full Mad King and completely
gone against everything her character
has stood for for almost eight seasons
Dany has always been about the poor
slaves and the downtrodden but now she
doesn't give a [ __ ] a dead dragon and
missandei I guess is the price it takes
for the queen of Westeros to sacrifice
thousands of innocents I used to love
Dany and root for her now I hate her
without even understanding where she's
coming from because that place where
she's coming from seems so disingenuous
to the character we've grown to love
over the last eight seasons the writing
has gone so fast that it comes across as
rushed and forced to make it even worse
she now threatens Tyrion telling him if
he screws up again it will be his last
time you might as well have a giant sign
here that reads Daenerys will die next
episode and what's the fun in that we
then get the scene where Arya the person
who has killed the night King tells the
soldier she's going to kill Queen Cersei
but it's so pointless first of all why
does this scene even exist
second of all we spent season seeing how
Arya is the perfect assassin even being
able to infiltrate the phrase and kill
their entire house how come she can't do
the same thing and get into King's
Landing the unsullied don't seem to know
that Tyrion is the prisoner Jamie's
brother and he's able to free him really
easily
just like how Jamie freed Tyrion in
season 4 no problem at all
antarians plan is so far-fetched have
Jamie escape with the Queen in a dinghy
past a fleet of ships unnoticed but the
worst of all is he'd be letting his
sister go the sister who he hates with
all his soul who he knows is truly an
evil person because the queen of the
Seven Kingdoms in a one-handed Jaime
Lannister can just you know start a new
life without anyone noticing
this also goes entirely against Tyrians
character who in season four wished he
could watch Cersei swallow poison and
die in front of them Tyrion and Jaime
hug in what could be their final scene
together the golden company prepare for
battle while the hound and Arya make
their way into the inner ramparts of
King's Landing now here is where things
start to get unbelievably bad Danny
decides to take on a fleet almost 10
times as big as the one that took down
Rhaegar last episode all by herself each
one of these ships and the ballista on
the shoreline are armed with the same
dragon piercing arrows is like flying
into a death trap and shows us she
learned nothing from her past mistakes
but somehow all 100 of these ships can't
hit the dragon
one last episode just a few of them
could multiple times meanwhile at the
front gates Harry Strickland the leader
of the golden company is one shotted by
an arrow in the back we never get to see
him fight and his men are completely
obliterated by drogon what was the point
of this character what was the point of
the golden company this is just another
example of a character who is built up
but there's absolutely no payoff this
brings me to one of my main criticisms
of this episode the battle is completely
one-sided at least in the Lord of the
Rings the Battle of Helm's Deep we watch
our heroes fight an almost
insurmountable foe as this situation
gets more dire with small victories
giving us glimpses of Hope sprinkles
here and there here it's just drogon
killing the [ __ ] out of everything and
that's it there's almost no tension
because the battle is so one-sided the
golden company is wiped out almost
instantly and the Lannisters surrender
where is the battle we were promised for
eight seasons it's not in this episode
the Lannister army completely surrenders
and the bells are
which tyrion told john means the queen
has surrendered and what does Danny do
she literally has the entire city in her
grasp she goes full targaryen and burns
the [ __ ] out of everything
it's like watching eight seasons of a
character you love in the span of two
episodes turn into Jack Torrance from
The Shining here's Johnny I'm not saying
she can't go full Mad Queen I'm saying
it needs to be earned and that takes
proper time and development which only a
few episodes can't do I mean for God's
sakes
everyone has surrendered and she's just
needlessly killing hundreds of civilians
this causes grey worm to attack all
those soldiers who surrendered I used to
like gray worm but now his actions make
him so unlikable his whole arc of
showing how an insult to love is gone to
[ __ ] that Ark took seasons to build but
only one episode to destroy and can we
talk about this scene where Jon saves a
woman who's about to be raped what was
the point of this it serves no point to
the plot at all we already know Danny's
army are the villains here killing
needlessly where do you know John is a
good guy and will protect the innocent
it just seems so cliche contrived and
unwarranted you're on and Jamie
conveniently meet along the shores where
instead of banding together to save the
queen' both of whom thinks she has their
child decide to battle it out and I
don't know there's just something so
unsatisfactory of Jamie getting stabbed
by Joran twice and Euron seems cool with
dying since I guess he's the one who
killed Jamie Lannister but we all know
he just dies two bricks cool I guess
clogging gives a speech to Aria about
revenge something he's been wanting all
his life and she just changes her mind
right then and there like one little
speech made her change her mind about
getting to Cersei even though she's been
wanting her dead since season one oh and
can we also talked about the Deus Ex
Mackinaw trouble which manages to kill
almost all of Circe's cards allowing
Clegane to get to her but there's one
cool thing that does happen the mountain
just Chuck's Qyburn into the wall that
was pretty cool I'll give him that Jamie
manages to make her way to Cersei even
though he was mortally stabbed twice and
this whole Jaime Cersei thing is one of
the biggest disappointments of this
series for the past eight seasons we've
seen Jaime's slowly drift away
from Cersei and become a changed man yet
in this moment his love for her Trump's
all the terrible [ __ ] she's done to him
in the past eight years of character
change for Jaime has literally meant
nothing he still sides by her regardless
of everything that has happened
he left Brienne for this people we then
get about five minutes of Aria just
running through the crowded destruction
of King's Landing which looks great but
offers no real service to the plot we
don't learn anything new about Aria
heerd or are given any new insight to
how the battle is unfolding this is the
woman who killed the night king and
she's subjected to a few scenes of
running with civilians through the
streets Clegane ultimately kills the
mountain by tackling him through the
side of the tower into a fiery pit below
having both of them die was a bit of a
cop-out to me I would have liked to seen
the mountain die in a fire just like how
the mountain burned clay Gaines faces a
child not both of them fly into fiery
pit but that's just me there was just
something that left me wanting from
cleganebowl and can we also discuss up
John was like completely useless this
episode and just like willy-nilly was
through the streets of King's Landing
where he could have gotten killed by
Danny and Rogen like does she not know
how she could be potentially killing him
too and at this point winning King's
Landing looks like it's the equivalent
of winning her Oshima it's just a
complete mess of destruction making me
question what the point of this was
anyway is the Iron Throne still even
there or has it been burnt to a crisp
then we have this mother daughter who
we've been watching this whole episode
who simply get burnt to a crisp
I'm not exactly sure what their point
was maybe to show the inhumanity of war
which we kind of already get by the
hundreds of burning corpses but hey
whatever Arya survives Jaime brings
Cersei to the bottom of the red keep
only to find their exit blocked by
debris
yes debris strikes again and Cersei
tells Jaime she doesn't want to die like
this you're telling me we spent eight
years in the last shot we get of them is
with a bunch of bricks falling on them
yep no redemption no catharsis just some
full-on brick action eight years of
nothing and for Arya it looks like
winter has come except instead of snow
it's the ash of a burning city Arya kill
the night King to prevent such horrors
from happening but it looks like
humanity can be just as destructive we
also get this scene of Aria and what
appears to be Harry Strickland's white
horse really the whole purpose of this
scene is to get her out of King's
Landing but with all the set design here
effects and makeup you're telling me
they didn't have enough money to have
John say goodbye to ghost and the
episode ends right there no real
cliffhanger just a bunch of unanswered
questions and more unsatisfactory
character arc deaths than actual deaths
now forgive me because I'm writing this
at 2:00 a.m. in the morning but are we
not going to revisit ilaria sand is this
actually how Jamie is gonna bow out my
main gripe is not that many of these
characters died in this stupid way but
they did so without achieving a
satisfying emotional art whether that
art be tragic or redemptive now maybe
Jamie and Cersei aren't dead and they'll
come back hiding under the skull of that
dead dragon but the damage is already
done
now I hung on this show even until this
last episode but I can't any longer
we'll always have the journey I guess
but what do you guys think is this still
the greatest TV show of all time or have
things taken a turn for the worse I bet
I'm gonna get a lot of hate for this
video so I'd appreciate a like if you
could swing it my way and you can chew
me out on Twitter at the big story
whitey until next time remember daddy
loves you very much